so I am a big believer that it's not
healthy to keep anything inside if you
can laugh at things that you're
embarrassed about you out nothing to be
ashamed of I really believe that so in
this next segment I'm going to read an
overshare from an audience member and
they're going to read and overshare from
me for a real segment with real things
that we call audience overshare let's
welcome our first audience overshare
this is Brooke citron everybody Brooke
Brooke are you okay
no you are great do you get a lot of
like citron vodka I do I do I do a lot
of Iowans detron like the vodka Nevin
heard that a million times it's great to
be here next time someone says you get a
lot of citron vodka jokes you should go
absolutely okay yours was yours is
funnier thanks for coming seriously so
honestly Brooke thank you for playing
this is mine and I will I'm going to
read yours this is uh Brooks real
overshare
I still wear clothing that I bought when
I was in seventh grade yes that includes
bras
yeah that happened yeah we could see a
graph it would just be a line yeah it's
actually somebody's out there making
boob graphs like anyone ever ruler Oh
just like my brother yeah do I really
yeah you do you're gonna dis joke like
against the wall
oh he cause you play out yeah he's an
good save I think you're lovely Brooke
why don't you read my over share okay
hmm
when I visit home my mother wakes me up
for Church by opening my bedroom door
without knocking laying on the bed and
singing hymns okay
that's worse no not haha that's way
worse okay I'll take it thank you so
much Brooke that's Brooke citron
everybody thank you
this ah this next overshare is named
Kailyn hall everybody let's welcome
Kailyn hall okay
nice to meet you nice to meet you so
here's my over shirt down here you go
I feel that it's easier to overshare if
we talk about something banal up top is
it banal
this is Kalin's oh for sure everybody
one time at a Halloween maze I punched a
small fool I punched a small child in
the face because he jumped out at me
dressed as an evil clown kaylynn we're
gonna have to rename the segment heroes
of humanity
cuz that demon child you don't know
what's coming at ya I didn't if there
was a place like a real demon were to go
to be like ah sweet pic of us it would
be like a Halloween themed maze you did
the right thing thank you thank you uh
so why don't you read me when I was
little I was always filling my own butt
like in class
I couldn't stop feeling my own butt it's
like a lava lamp in my panic yeah thank
you so much really people can listen you
punch it
punch in the face I peel my back so
punch in the face